hi there I'm Jennifer Garner and I'm
going to take a BuzzFeed quiz to find
out which Jennifer Garner
character I am first choose a Hollywood
hunk Ryan Gosling
Henry quilting great Mark Ruffalo Josh
Duhamel Matthew McConaughey Will Smith
ideal and how do you choose one of these
guys I mean it's hard not to choose one
of them that I know Matthew have worked
with twice so he went speak next pick
your favorite movie genre horror no
action I'm in an action film and I do
like this film but typically I get too
stressed out no thank you rom-com yes
sci fi no fantasy Luna comedy yes
rom-com or comedy we have to go rom-com
now choose your favorite Jennifer
Gardner red carpet logo what's
horrifying the 60th Golden Globes wow we
were really going for a period look with
the hair over the years with 54th Emmy
Awards that was Ralph Lauren it was
pretty and that dress didn't come
together until that day 75th Academy
Awards definitely not her the 88th
Academy Awards ah the long bang that's
one of my favs 88 the Academy Awards
that's Versace and the 90th Academy
Awards whoa that blue dress was very
blue which one is the most me I really
loved the hair and the drama of this
take that pick your go to movie theaters
snack wine
choose a punny name for your pet chicken
mother clucker oh that's good Dixie
chick Princess Leia
these are very good Gretch hen wiener
I'm not gonna lie this is the toughest
one we've come across Gobi hen
hmm I am I'm Jenna rink I could have
told you that without doing this the
person that I am closest to is
generating yes I'm thirty flirty and
thriving plus sixteen years whether
you're closer in age to thirty or
thirteen or the two combined you are the
livable and self determined generate
people tend to be attracted to your
vibrant personality and infectious
presence and who can blame them
you're the life of the party in any
setting with or without whipping out the
thrill a choreography I still know
throwing though you have a tendency to
want to fit in with the cool crowd I
don't think that is true about me just
that specific thing I'm not very good at
the cool crap you never stray too far
away from your authentic self I almost
forgot your flirty and thriving booty
yeah I would agree with that I think I'm
probably of all the characters I've ever
played I'm probably most like that chick
you
[Music]